i also don't think that it's a total
secret that i have a bit of a rebellious
streak
i know you may be shocked by that
but you know there's a lot of positive
things that you can learn from breaking
the rules
one time i wanted to get to the next
place and i illegally parked my bronco
in a parking lot that got gated up and i
decided to drive that bronco right
through the gates and smash them open
i kind of learned just to call a taxi
now
i want to push that spirit even further
so today we're finding new ways to
break the rules
every once in a while i act like i have
a libido
now in order to do that we've got our
rebel rule book yes
now here are a few women who helped
define the rebel rule book
set it on fire u.s women's soccer team
superstar
megan repino come on she is always
kicking conformity to the curb
she crushes on the field and she refuses
to be censored off of it
greta tunberg the ultimate teen rebel
and someone who really changed my life
last year
she really did she had a huge effect on
me i
really changed single-use plastics and
just
my styrofoam cups and i found new ways
of living because i was so inspired by
her she shows up on parliament's
doorstep
on a friday ditching school by the way i
feel you greta
to change the world hey model winnie
harlow
i love her because she reinvented beauty
standards and became the beacon of
positivity and she is straight up drop
dead gorgeous
bozama saint john okay you have to know
about this woman
she's amazing she was apple music's
former head of marketing
apple come on now she's just the cmo of
a little company called
netflix she even runs a workshop on how
to be a badass in business
let's all watch her and learn so on that
note let's see
what rebel related news made the papers
today
all right cnn they ran this piece and i
want to share it with you
they're saying that now is the perfect
time
to give up perfectionist parenting i
love that they stopped telling you a
24-hour news cycle and actually got
really philosophical
because this is a subject we're all
struggling so
i say thank you cnn finally
because this past year we've been in
each other's business with so much
anxiety we're gonna have to learn to
loosen that monkey tight grip
that's cutting off my circulation and
learn to let it go but i'm not real good
at letting it go so i'm going to my
friend of the show
and our guru dr elisa pressman of
raising good humans podcast dr elisa
help
we need you why i love you first of all
i love you too why why do parents have
to feel like they have to be perfect
because you know our kids whether we
like it or not
are a reflection of ourselves and the
more you expect
perfection from yourself the nastier
that voice is in your own head
the more you're going to expect it of
your parenting and
your kids learn they should expect it of
themselves so you can get rid of it if
you just
remind yourself i don't want my kid to
grow up yelling at themselves inside
their head that they have to be perfect
so i'm going to make a lot of mistakes
in front of them boom you don't have to
be a perfect parent
okay so how do we let ourselves off the
hook well
whenever that inner voice isn't nice
truly
take a moment and imagine oliver frankie
is talking to themselves like that and
you will stop
and also let them do what they're
capable of
and then guide and support them in
things that they're almost capable of
and only teach and model where they
really really need you
and the rest you know back off is it
true
that we lead by example that if
i am living a higher road life a little
more gentle
a little more enlightened a little more
patient with myself that that will
actually have
the right trickle down and exampling to
my kids
yes that's why if you pause
and you just go wait is this what i want
them to hear in their head
even if they can't hear the inside of
your head
they know they know how you're talking
to yourself i love you so much
i'm calling you after the show thank you
elisa
you are the perfect expert to help us
de-perfect ourselves and set a new
standard
thank you
you